this episode of shots of awe is brought
to you by Norton
so I'm very passionate about technology
and most people think of technology as a
set of tools that expand our creative
capacity somewhat a set of tools that
provide useful services in the world but
I believe that there's a hidden
dimension at play here I believe that
there's this hidden dimension to
technology that's actually metaphysical
it was explored brilliantly in the work
of Erik Davis and the book tech gnosis
consider the example of amber case
cyborg anthropologist she says every
time you make a telephone call
Skype call essentially collapsing
geography you're essentially
transcending the limits of space of time
of distance your thoughts Electrify
traveling at quasi the speed of light
connecting you with another mind in real
time and the kind of technologically
mediated telepathy to use the term by
david porsche and so these telephone
calls these techno social wormholes
reveal themselves to be a kind of divine
engineering we've become the alchemical
gods
you know Andy Clark in his book Natural
Born cyborg says that the mind the
modern human mind actually emerges in
the feedback loops between brains these
tools that we create in the environment
in which we create
we're thinking through our iPhones and
and Samsung phones we're thinking on the
Internet we're thinking on the page
you know we build the tool and the tool
builds us we are designed by that which
we have designed and because we are
coupled to these tools and because these
tools promised to be conduits to
transcending our biological limitations
perhaps we should be sympathetic to the
reason that would run in droves to buy
the new smartphone when it comes out
we're literally getting a mind upgrade a
wetware upgrade these are not trivial
things these are not fashion accessories
these are mind where upgrades